the professor I'm calling up now has
written five New York Times bestsellers
and for 20 years she's been studying our
emotions our shame and vulnerability our
courage and empathy usually she does so
from her office at the University of
Houston but lately she's been able to
study emotions close up quarantined with
her own family so maybe she'll
appreciate a break
[Music]
dr. Brenner Brown thank you so much for
taking the time thank you
I'm excited I was listening to your
podcast it's called unlocking house and
I get the impression that from your
perspective now it's okay to feel sorry
for ourselves what do you mean by that
I would I would frame it probably
differently which I would probably just
say I think it's okay to feel I think I
think we're experiencing grief fear
anxiety uncertainty vulnerability and
the only way through that is to
acknowledge it if we spend all of our
energy and effort trying to pretend like
we're okay
when we're not that actually it's
counterintuitive but that's actually the
thing that keeps us from being okay so I
don't know if this is gonna translate or
not because this is such a fifth
generation Texan so this is such a Texas
saying but when we were growing up we
were always told you know don't piss and
moan like just complaining and so my
whole thinking now is you can complain
and you can feel but just have some
perspective like one of the things I see
happening here and probably all over the
world is people are ranking they're
suffering they're saying I'm not allowed
to be sad because I have a safe home and
resources and then people are saying but
you know I'm
not allowed to be sad because I'm sick
because I'm not dead you know it's we
keep thinking who only the people who
have it the worst are allowed to feel
struggle not helpful everything we've
learned shows us that comparative
suffering helps no one including those
who are the most wounded so I would say
you don't have to compare but you do
need to maintain perspective you have to
maintain perspective and I'll tell you
where that's tough how so let me ask you
this it's quite interesting are our kids
in the u.s. who are missing big ritual
ceremonies graduations from high school
and college are really struggling is
that something you're experiencing as
well oh yes oh yes absolutely so here's
where it gets difficult because if we
can kind of agree that that it's you
have to have perspective perspective is
a function of experience right the more
experience we have in life the more
perspective we have and so for kids if
they're missing their high school
graduation or their college graduation
or this event they don't have you know
40 50 years of perspective to put that
in place their lives are smaller and
their experiences are limited and it
doesn't help us to look at our kids and
say hey suck it up get over it you think
you've got that bad let me tell you
about what it was like you know it's not
helpful they're little crisis is is big
enough for them I mean our hearts are
big enough to hold space for everyone's
hurt empathy compassion are not finite
it's not like pizza it's not like oh I'm
gonna give you a piece and now I only
have seven left it doesn't work that way
the more we recognize hurt and other
people and meet that with compassion
more compassion we have so so what about
yourself how much self-pity do you do
you feel these days have you have you
have you felt some self-pity exercise
some self-control for kid yesterday give
yourself a break
you know my husband and I have been
together for over 30 years and I was
like I don't think we really know each
other I just don't think this is gonna
work out at all because you know
everyone's just I'm an introvert too so
I'm not used to sharing space with
people oh that's a difficult one now
yeah because you you're you're in the
lock down right yes and have been for 11
weeks with my husband my 20 year old
came home from university my 14 year old
my sister's their kids and family and
then my mother and her husband yeah you
you kind of miss your little office of
the University I guess but but if I
understand you right one shouldn't feel
shame for for having this kind of for
grieving in a way for grieving over what
we can't experience now yeah let me walk
you through this kind of tangled but
super important landscape of emotion so
if we're having a hard time and we're
like man I just feel I feel disappointed
I feel sad and then I feel shame because
Who am I to feel disappointed and sad
I've got it so much better than other
people what's interesting is that shame
and empathy cannot coexist so when we
shame ourselves for feeling sad or
down or exhausted it leaves us with less
empathy to care about people who really
need support and love shame is not a
compass for moral behavior it's it
leaves us less capable of love for self
and for others it's not helpful and I
have it's also self occupying I mean
feeling shame yeah yeah so so that's
that's the best word I never used that
word I'm writing it down self occupying
because shame is completely centered on
self where empathy is outwardly focused
on others shame is much more likely to
be the cause of destructive behaviors
than the cure for destructive behaviors
shame is far too dangerous of an
instrument to be helpful and so that you
know the hardest problem I have honestly
and I haven't talked about this publicly
with anyone the thing that can make me
feel the most that can be the most
potentially shaming for me right now is
the feelings of rage that I have toward
people who have politicized this and are
not following the rules and not
following science and following the
leadership at least here that is not
effective brave or science driven right
now that can make me crazy and then
sometimes I'm thinking okay break the
rules you know you get sick that's your
fault and I don't want to be that person
but I can get enraged sometimes about
the people that are putting other people
at risk because of their selfishness you
just written a book about leadership
it's called dare to lead I know that you
talked about over function errs and
under functions if you can just explain
that that definition okay so over
functioning and under functioning are
two patterned way
that we have AB dealing with stress and
anxiety and so some of us when we get
anxious over function we become
controlling micromanaging the boss of
everybody in some of us under function
and anxiety which means when things get
hard we don't show up a hundred percent
and so what I think courageous
leadership looks like right now and
always which we're not seeing at least
here is courageous leadership is empathy
it is being a learner and wanting to get
it right it is and this is a big one
armored leaders the leaders who are you
know are all protected and self
protected and take care of themselves
first expect to be served by people
brave leaders are in service of people
brave leaders make hard decisions even
if they're unpopular they don't spend
their time on social media trying to
gauge their popularity let's let's talk
about anxiety I mean how people respond
to anxiety how people in respond to
feeling feeling afraid you you talk
about the the over functioning people on
the under functioning people who are you
yourself over function er I see oh yeah
oldest of four my code name is sister
superior like definitely I'm an over
function ER and you know I used to think
well if you have to be an over function
or an under function er it'd be much
better to be an over function ER because
at least you'll get [__] done right but
as it turns out it's also very toxic you
know in times of anxiety we're reacting
to a loss of control and the you know
and here's what's interesting anxiety is
the most contagious of all human
emotions so a lot of researchers will
say that anxiety is a never a function
of individuals it's always a function of
groups because one one
one person goes everybody goes and so
the antidote to anxiety is calm because
calm is also contagious and so what I
try to do at work is when people start
getting ratcheted happenings and anxious
because we make terrible decisions and
anxiety I try to be a force of calm I
try to take deep breaths talk softer
talk slower you know so now many people
all over the world are stuck at home
there might be many people there perhaps
we're a bit low on batteries all of us
how should we behave when it's like that
we developed this system because I
travel a lot for work my husband's a
physician both kind of has stressful
jobs and so we had this system where I
would come home from a trip and I would
be thinking the whole way home in the
back of the car from the airport thank
God I'm getting home thank God I'm just
gonna collapse and rest this has been so
hard you know blah blah blah and I had
no idea that he was thinking thank god
she's coming home because I need to rest
taking care of the kids and my job and
everything has been so hard so I opened
the back door he'd be like hey here are
the kids and here's where some soccer
uniform and here are the goggles and
that you know the cleats and I'd be like
hey I'm home take care of everything I
need to rest
and so it would cause a lot of tension
so we started doing this thing where
when we saw each other we would tell
each other where we were on our battery
so I would get home from a trip and I
would say hey I'm at 20 and he'd say oh
no cuz I'm at 22 and we'd say okay so
we're missing 60 what do we need to do
and so we had ground rules that our kids
helped us make up that was they were
very simple they were you know use nice
words like don't yell and scream and be
mean use nice words use a face that's
nice to do sometimes I'd say nice words
and my kids would be like oh your face
does not
those words apologize when you're wrong
have more fun and so so that worked and
it really taught me that all of the
advice I got before I got married about
marriage as being 50/50 was total BS
because good marriages are not 50/50
good marriages are you can come up with
90 when your partner has ten but it's
not sustainable but you can also count
on your partner to come up with 90 when
you have 10 because that's the reality
right we're not always like 50% the
pandemic has been hard because for the
first time I think Steve and I have had
to struggle with what happens when you
both only have 10 or 15 for a long
period of time like when I tell Steve
when things are really hard is like
let's zoom out and pretend like we're
over the house watching us and we're
watching how we're interacting what
would we say and I said he said we would
look each other and say that's a couple
under a lot of stress under
extraordinary circumstances they need to
give themselves a break right um this
goes for many many couples no I think
every couple like I have a friend that
texted me the other day and she said
getting a divorce and I and I said no
sudden moves like this is not it's like
my husband tells patients all the time
don't make any big decisions about
staying married when you've got any kids
that are still under four III actually I
have a four year old and when I he's got
this this friend that is he's a three
year old and he's very gloomy I'm the
serious person the today.this three
years old he came to me and he said you
know that we're all gonna die yeah yeah
yeah that's the case right and then he
kept repeating it so he said like four
times you know that we're all gonna die
and I was
thinking I have to ask you about this is
how should we talk to our kids about
this situation how well how much should
we involve them I mean kids are very
much feelings and they are very much
very much sensibility and so much sense
I think we we are developmentally
appropriately factual I don't think we
done things down and you know I think if
you're the three-year-old I would say
well everything alive at some point dies
we don't have any reason to believe that
you're not going to have a long life and
that I'm not going to have a long life
and then they said well when do you
think you're going to die you can say
that's a scary and great question I
don't have the answer that no one does
and that's part of what makes living
both hard and beautiful you use a term
called mirror neurons can you explain
that mirror neurons are Jets when we
talk about this idea that we're
hardwired for connection we are actually
built - for empathy to be able to
reflect back what other people are
feeling to be able to feel in ourselves
what we see in others and so when people
say you know it sounds like a great
marketing slogan we're built for
connection we're hardwired for you know
belonging but the truth is we're
actually at a cellular level built to be
in connection with other people and in
the absence of connection they're
suffering and in fact we do know that
when people experience social pain
they're pushed out of a group they're
rejected someone breaks up with them the
same part of the brain lights up as when
they feel physical pain so if you poured
if you accidentally poured scalding
coffee on your hand there's a part
there's the brain receptors indeed that
would light up and we would be able to
see that if I hurt you emotionally it
would be the same and so the whole
everybody
myself included at times we want to
believe that we're cognitive rational
beings who on occasion feel but the
truth is that we are feeling people
emotional beings who on occasion think
and much more our lives are driven by
emotions than cognition should should
that it's that good if you're a leader
as well it's good that you know that and
what I can tell you is in you know 10 15
years of spending 90% of my time in
organizations working with leaders every
fortune 100 company probably in the
United States not every but many many of
them I have never met a transformational
leader who does not understand their own
emotional landscape and is not fluent in
the emotional landscape of other people
emotional understanding and emotional
literacy is a irreducible prerequisite
for courageous leadership brené Brown
your book dare to lead is out in Swedish
and English thank you very much ok stay
there why I hope you enjoyed the clip
for more interesting conversations
please hit subscribe
you